AND AS USUAL
I DON’T EVEN KNOW HIS NAME.
I’M TRYING TO GET DRESSED
QUICKLY AND GET OUT OF THERE
BEFORE HE WAKES UP,
BUT I CAN’T FIND MY UNDERWEAR.
I LOOK EVERYWHERE,
BUT I JUST CAN’T FIND THEM,
AND THEN IT HITS ME.
I HAD LEFT THEM AT ANOTHER GUY’S
APARTMENT EARLIER THAT NIGHT,
AND THAT’S WHEN I KNEW
I HAD A PROBLEM.
- THANKS FOR SHARING, SCOTTY.
WELL, I NOTICE A LOT
OF NEW FACES THIS EVENING,
AND I’M SO GLAD YOU ALL CAME,
AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
THIS IS A SAFE PLACE TO SHARE.
SO IF YOU WANT TO TELL US
YOUR STORY,
THERE’LL BE NO JUDGMENT.
- SURE, I’LL GO.
HI, Y’ALL.
NAME’S WENDELL,
AND I AM IN FACT
A SEXUAL ADDICT.
all: HI, WENDELL.
- AND WHAT BRINGS YOU HERE,
WENDELL?
- WELL, YOU KNOW, MY LIFE,
SEXUALLY SPEAKING, IS CRAZY,
AND I JUST WANT TO FIND
ONE SINGLE SOLITARY PERSON
TO SPEND THE REST
OF MY LIFE WITH.
JUST ONE, JUST ONE.
- SO DO YOU FEEL LIKE
YOUR ADDICTION IS
TOO MUCH TO HANDLE RIGHT NOW?
- DUH.
I MEAN, IT’S BEEN CRAZY, Y’ALL.
WITH ME, THE NASTIER
THE BETTER.
I’M A DIRTY DOG.
TRY EVERYTHING, ALL THE FIXINGS.
TANTRIC, MUCH LIKE STING.
ALL THE BELLS AND WHISTLES.
YOU NAME IT, I’VE DONST IT.
- AND WHEN WOULD YOU SAY
YOU HIT ROCK BOTTOM, WENDELL?
- WHEN IT GOT SLIPPERY
OUTSIDE MY SHOWER,
ON THE FLOOR
OUTSIDE MY SHOWER.
OH.
I HIT ROCK BOTTOM SEXUALLY--
OH, IT WAS PROBABLY LAST NIGHT,
LAST NIGHT.
- DO YOU THINK THAT YOU COULD
TELL US WHAT HAPPENED, WENDELL?
- YEAH, LET’S SEE.
IT WAS JUST LIKE
ANY OTHER NIGHT.
I HAD ORDERED A LARGE PIE,
PEPPERONI,
PINEAPPLE, CHEESY CRUST,
SOME CHEESY BREAD ON THE SIDE.
CUT TO 30 "MIN" LATER,
PIZZA PARLOR SENT OVER A
DELICIOUS LADY DELIVERY PERSON.
BODY TEN, FACE TEN.
THAT’S MY WEAKNESS.
SO I INVITED HER INSIDE,
OPENED UP THE BOX.
IT WAS HOT.
DEVOURED THE FIRST SLICE
LICKETY-SPLIT, CRUST FIRST.
SECOND SLICE
DIDN’T STAND A CHANCE.
ATE THE TIP OF THAT BITCH FIRST,
WASHED IT DOWN WITH A POP.
THEN I GOT NASTY
WITH THE CHEESY BREAD.
MY HEART STARTED POUNDING HARDER
THAN USUAL, KER-SLUNK,
KER-SLUNK.
MOVED ON TO THE THIRD SLICE--
- WHAT--
WHAT--WHAT ABOUT THE GIRL?
- WHAT GIRL?
OH, THE GIRL.
YEAH, SHE WAS THERE TOO.
I INVITED HER INTO MY BOUDOIR,
AKA "THE STABBIN’ CABIN."
WE DISROBED ONE ANOTHER.
I TOUCHED HER ON HER GENITALIA.
SHE TOUCHED ME ON MY MAN-ITALIA,
AND THAT’S WHEN I HIT IT.
SEXUALLY, OF COURSE,
UPSTAIRS, DOWNSTAIRS,
ALL AROUND THE TOWN STAIRS,
AS YOU DO,
AND BY THEN
IT WAS JUST ANOTHER NIGHT,
AND I MEAN OIL EVERYWHERE,
AND...
SAUCE ALL OVER ME.
- S-SAUCE?
- OH, YEAH,
THAT’S MY WORD FOR...
EJACULATE.
ANYHOO, I’M SO DISTRAUGHT
BECAUSE I FEEL VULNERABLE,
AND I DON’T KNOW.
I JUST FEEL LIKE ANYONE
COULD TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF ME RIGHT NOW,
A-NY-ONE.
’KAY, LET’S SEE WHAT THE BLONDES
HAVE TO SAY FIRST.
- WELL, THANK YOU, WENDELL.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING.
IT’S ACTUALLY OUR TIME TODAY.